une carte d'entrée pour la cantine
scolaire on ne mange plus à la carte
depuis un an les écoliers juif ou
musulman de cette école n'ont plus le
choix de manger autre chose que de la
viande de porc
quand on leur présente et avocats cette
mairie il y avait des des plats de
substitution quand il ya vu du corps oui
il faut donner à la place du port
le ben laden dont le directeur de
l'école ne cache pas son indignation
que dois je faire des enfants qui me
semble comme filles et de 8h30 à 17h30
et qui n'ont pas la possibilité d'avoir
un repas qui leur permettre de faire
face à nos journées scolaires 150 élèves
sont concernés à marignane par la mesure
municipale une mesure jugée par la
direction de l'école comme étant
inhumaines et éminemment politique
générale de restauration m'a dit que non
seulement c'est à la demande de la
mairie mais la municipalité demandé de
mettre davantage de porc dans le menu
donc je passe je pas profondeur la
question et vous savez très bien quel
est le contenu qui est derrière ça
mettre davantage de portes dans les
menus c'est vouloir faire de cette
attitude une mesure de vexations à
l'égard de la communauté musulmane
les familles ont évoqué devant le
tribunal administratif la violation de
la liberté religieuse mais elles ont été
déboutées par ce même tribunal
marseillais certains parents ont pour le
moment décidé de retirer leurs enfants
de la cantine quand il ya du porc n'est
tous feront appel du jugement il ya des
spécialistes on aura affaire à des
avocats qui vont faire des recherches
on va faire appel s'il faut justement
écrire au président de la république on
va le faire mais on se laissera pas
faire
à la mairie de marignane on campe aussi
sur ses positions l'adjoint aux affaires
scolaires qui est aussi instituteur
remplaçant dans les écoles de la ville
mène une vraie bataille idéologique je
n'entre pas dans les creepers de
religion ce qui nous concerne pas
l'école est publique laïque à marignane
ce soir rien ne laisse espérer qu'un
dialogue pourra s'installer entre la
mairie du front national et les adultes
qui sont responsables de l'éducation des
enfants